quelques chiffres maintenant des données
assez encourageantes même s'il reste
encore beaucoup de chemin à faire selon
un rapport de l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture
la planète compte moins de personnes qui
souffrent de la faim qu'auparavant en
fait le nombre d'affamés a diminué de
près du quart en 25 ans 795 millions de
personnes sont sous alimentées
c'est une personne sur neuf dans le
monde alors qu'il y en avait 1 milliard
en 1992 on note des progrès marqués dans
plusieurs pays d'asie et d'amérique du
sud
les progrès dus en grande partie à des
conditions politiques stables et une
bonne croissance économique mais il y a
toujours très peu d'améliorations en
afrique subsaharienne qui demeure la
région du monde la plus touchée